good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I'm
back on the set of the Paper Towns movie
but over the last like 100 hours you and
me and the Catherine and both of our
parents had norovirus which is a virus
with this amazing superpower it can make
human beings stay on or near a toilet
for like 12 to 24 hours I don't think
why don't fictional characters ever get
sick like why is Captain Ahab never like
oh god I've got the worst head cold and
my throat is very scratchy and I just
want to stay in my bunk but if I don't
get up and try to find the white whale
human beings will never learn about
nature's complete indifference to them
so I guess I'll go to work anyway while
I was horrific ly ill I kept wondering
who exactly was responsible for my
norovirus the thing is Hank you get
norovirus almost all the time by eating
the poop of someone who already has it
now you only have to eat like point zero
zero zero zero one grams in order to get
norovirus but it is I want to emphasize
this someone else's poop now the clear
patient zero in our family is my
daughter Alice five days before
Thanksgiving she awoke from a nap and
promptly vomited all over her father but
I didn't get sick then I mentioned this
only because it leads to the
uncomfortable awareness that in all
likelihood all of us have eaten the poop
of everyone we love I guess except that
if it's an internet relationship man
internet friendships are the best the
next time someone says to me like all
your internet friendships aren't real
I'll be like listen if your construction
of reality involves necessarily eating
poop then I'm going to stay right here
in my land of fiction
anyway this poop eating business is
great stuff to think about when you're
already extremely queasy from norovirus
but the other thing I kept thinking is
that my beautiful one-year-old daughter
whose poop had started this whole
Thanksgiving family catastrophe was
going to be okay like norovirus is
almost never fatal in kids in the US but
around the world that causes more than
200,000 child deaths per year and most
of those kids die for want of clean
water and oral rehydration solution that
costs like 50 cents Alice got Pedialyte
that's the only difference between ha ha
what a funny Thanksgiving family story
and the greatest personal disaster I can
imagine
and whatever Alice goes up to do
whatever any of us grow up to do let's
remember all those times that everything
rested on 50 cents of Pedialyte or
refrigerated penicillin or access to
clean water now of course the actual
process of getting oral rehydration
solutions to the kids who need it is
like
everything in global health and poverty
fiendishly complicated but I don't think
we should let that complexity stand in
our way or intimidate us yes it is hard
and yes there are failures but
organizations from Save the Children to
water.org to countless local charities
are helping to decrease child mortality
I think I am in no way grateful from my
brush with norovirus but it's helpful to
think about as we head into project for
awesome season the world is a profoundly
unjust place it always has been and I
imagine it always will be
but that doesn't absolve us of our
responsibility to look directly at
problems even when they are painful to
look at and to try our best to do
something to decrease worldsuck
so Hank I'm sorry that you ate Alice's
poop or possibly my poop somebody's poop
anyway but here's to the hope of getting
better both individually and as a
species Hank I'll see you on Friday